I want to talk with you for the
remainder of the night about what is
sustainable business and the technical
challenges of sustainable business which
means what are the technologies that are
needed for businesses to become more
sustainable the financial issues that
are key to sustainability the fourth
topic will be the organizational and
management challenges and finally the
role of government and public policy in
helping to promote business
sustainability and this is going to be
the same framework you're going to see
throughout the rest of the semester I'll
talk about technology finance management
and policy in politics that that
framework is really how I looked at all
of the sustainability issues in the new
book sustainability management that
you're previewing this semester so what
is sustainable business now originally
as I mentioned in the first hour
Environmental Protection regulated
pollution to end of the pipeline add-ons
the factory was there it spewed stuff
into the environment and we developed
some kind of control technology to treat
the emissions or the effluent we didn't
think about stopping the stuff from
being produced are changing production
processes we basically focused on
pollution control and this is basic
first generation approach to
environmental protection you see this in
the 1970s and 1980s one of the problems
here is that conceptually this is what
locked in this idea in people's minds
that there was a trade-off between
environmental protection and economic
growth retrofits added cost to the
production process okay you you had your
factory it produced something the waste
you didn't think about and you didn't
worry about and you didn't pay for so
you just dumped the stuff on the side of
the road you know in a way that was how
early industrial societies live that's
how I mean in New York City
garbage used to be thrown on the street
then it got thrown into the waterways
and then we dug a big hole for it in
Staten Island and we didn't we put it
there then the hole got filled up and
now we send it to holes in the ground in
Virginia and Pennsylvania but and and
now the cost of these things is going up
so we have to start paying some
attention to that but environmental
protection and a concern for
sustainability with Cena's money losers
not money makers you're not going to
make money doing this it's going to cost
you money so what changes what changes
you start to think about pollution as a
form of waste
if pollution is waste then if I can
produce less waste then I can make more
money if you think about a normal or a
factory and you know a factory like a
bicycle factory where the stuff goes
down the production line and then at the
end of the production line if the
bicycle isn't suitable for market it
gets thrown into the redo bid it gets
thrown into a different part of the
factory where it gets scavenged for
parts but that whole cost of product
producing that bicycle and putting it in
the redo bin adds to the price of the
things that actually are made well this
was actually one of the fundamental
management insights of Deming where he
looked at American car manufacturers and
command started to advise the Japanese
the story I sometimes tell about this
was I bought a duster in the mid-1970s
when I was in graduate school and when I
bought the duster it's a great car it
was like a truck three stick stick on
the floor and no power steering
you know parallel parking of this thing
was better than any kind of lifting you
could do in a gym but the thing about
the car is when I bought it the guy says
to me listen I want you to keep a pad
and paper on the seat next to you for
the first you know three or four weeks
with a car and you just write down
anything wrong with the car and
if the car has a defect I guarantee you
will fix it so I took my paddle left it
on the side and you know so the
windshield wipers didn't work not
life-threatening
one of the windows didn't crank right
and there were little things six or
seven little things and at the end of
three weeks I brought it in for the
first checkup and they know they fixed
everything you know and so I drove away
I was a happy customer what do I know
so then I bought a Honda in the mid-80s
and they I finished the deal and I say
to the Honda dealer so I'll keep a pad
on the seat next to me and I'll write
down anything that's wrong with the car
and you guys will fix it right and the
guy looked at me like I had done
something horrible to him and he said he
said there will be nothing wrong with
this car this car is perfect and so yeah
he's a car salesman that's perfect so I
drove around for several weeks with the
pad and there's nothing on it the car is
perfect and started to occur to me that
when I bought the the Duster I was still
helping to make the car I was the
quality control inspector but the Honda
got to be and it was all working okay
and what they had done with the Honda is
that they looked at every aspect of the
car over time so if a windshield wiper
motor worked seventy thousand times and
they could make it work ninety thousand
by changing a little brush in if they
would put the brush in and they did this
to every part of the car over a long
period of time in the Japanese cars
which in the 1970s were seen as of
inferior quality soon became the
standard because they applied this these
processes to thinking about the
production line so if you think about it
then you don't in the case of pollution
you don't want to treat and
decontaminate waste you want to drive it
out of the production process because
that means you're using something in the
course of production that you're not
selling isn't the idea when you make
something to sell it and make money off
of it so if I'm spewing into the
environment or trying to dump it into
the river that means I'm not using it in
production and so that's one of the
core concepts of sustainability
management that you want to be
parsimonious in your use of resources
not because you're you know Pete Seeger
or because you're thinking about the
environment but because you don't want
to pay for stuff you're not going to use
and you want to sell everything that you
that you buy and that you want to make
sure your production processes work that
way so as this kind of thinking goes
into organizations you start to
eliminate the growth environment
trade-off in fact the goal is to start
getting people to think about the
environment as the source of wealth that
you actually want to use it as
efficiently as possible so what are the
technical challenges then of sustainable
business the first is that we don't know
how to do this all the time okay
sustainable business requires closed
system production this is what's the
field of industrial ecology all of your
inputs after you process them come out
as product so you don't throw anything
out okay there's no if you if you're
producing something in there steam
that's produced in the process you
capture the steam and you use it to turn
a turbine and generate electricity
instead of spewing it out into the
environment if there's a chemical
effluent that comes out take a look at
what's in that chemical effluent and see
can we separate this in the production
process and sell it to somebody who
needs that chemical instead of sending
it into the Hudson River all resources
are used in production in this way of
thinking and all products then are
designed for reasons it's a design issue
so we send this computer out into the
marketplace
after 18 months the computer is no
longer sellable right or the probable
actually this is probably a better
example okay I mean how long do these
things last now I mean on your contracts
after every two years you get a free one
right so the whole system has been
geared up for you to replace these
things what do you do with the old
blackberries
the old you know iPhones where did
anybody here have an old iPhone that
they had to get rid of this year where
did it go only two people got rid of an
iPhone this year come on I have a drawer
in what in my desk at home that's filled
with these things I've got a dozen you
know I've got the flip phone and the you
know but the point is they're not
designed to be taken back and
remanufactured and they could be okay
that could be part you know imagine if
if the in the cost of production there
was a there was actually a system for
reuse now you have it in toner from from
HP right you put that you know basically
printers have become toner holders okay
the printer costs $80 the toner cost $80
this is not this is not an unusual
commercial practice Shea a razor blades
were the first of these things the razor
blade costs more than what holds it
because they're really in the business
of selling razor blades and so they
basically give away the actual shaver
okay the the point here is when the
products done can you take it back and
use it again and toner is very toxic and
they've even got a system now where the
box of the new one you put the old one
in right and UPS comes at their normal
pickup time when they're delivering
something they take it back in most
offices okay that's an example now why
does HP do this because they're nice
people and they care about the
environment I'm sure the nice people
they care about the environment but
they're doing it because they can take
that old packaging pour some more toner
in and sell it again and sell it again
and sell it again and so in that respect
you can you you have a sustainable
business now many many manufacturing
technologies ov and built on the
expectation that waste disposal was less
expensive than reuse and it still is the
cost of collection and of bringing that
stuff back what a pain in the neck let's
just get rid of it we don't need this
stuff again right
so that's
that's the the problem technically you
have to create the technologies around
the product that make it clear that by
reusing it and remanufacturing and
recycling it the manufacturer will
actually save money and as natural
resources get more expensive and as some
of these elements become scarce or
you'll see more and more of this and you
know you already see it for example in
the tire business we now do in fact pay
to have our tires taken so what are the
other technical challenges the needs of
design into a product an easier method
of reusing the product the second time
as that has to become a design
specification if the people who are
engineering and designing the product
don't think about it it's not going to
get done so whether it's a refrigerator
or it's an air-conditioner or it's a
computer now in some cases you know all
you can do is use parts of it but even
that's better than just throwing the
whole thing out reuse and reduced
resource consumption have to become
design specifications of people making
products you know and can this be done
yeah we know we've integrated lots of
new ideas into work processes I mean I
use the example of safety occupational
health and safety is something that you
know best example I know of is is
firefighting firefighters now have
oxygen tanks when they go into fighting
a fire why because the stuff inside
houses is increasingly toxic when it
burns but for a long time they didn't
have it so in New York City
the average asia' of mortality for a
firefighter is 62 years old and so the
the average age of of mortality for the
rest of us is closer to 80 and so
they've incorporated into their work
processes over time more and more of a
concern for safety so as Con Ed so have
many many industrial factories part of
its osha and their role but part of it
is actually the factories themselves
combination of regulation and thinking
of
and we're not trying to kill our people
here changing working conditions
computers and other electronics that are
designed for short life cycles need to
be changed for either longer-lasting so
you can plug in the new software
wouldn't it be better if the older
computers could run the next couple of
generations of software because in a way
they're not really event I mean they are
advancing in the sense that computer
memory and computer processing time is
technologically advancing getting
cheaper and better all the time and
that's part of why and then a software
designer says hey I can put something
else on this I couldn't do before and
that's why over time 18 months 24 months
you want to get rid of what you have
maybe there's a way to do that a little
bit differently okay so those are the
technical issues we the basic problems
we don't know how to do it all the time
okay and that's that's where and in some
cases we know how to do it but the
design specifications for the product
haven't been put in there yet you know
air conditioners maybe one of the best
examples I know of a place where design
specifications were added over the last
decade to the manufacturing of air
conditioners making them far more energy
efficient than they were before so that
that if you have an air conditioner it's
over five years old and you buy a new
one you'll pay for that air conditioner
in saved energy oh by the time you
finish with the second summer if not
sooner depending on how often you use
the thing okay so let's talk about the
financial side which is the next part
now businesses that use fewer resources
and produce less waste in theory should
be lower cost but here's the reality you
have some cost you have capital in place
if you're the sanitation department of
the city of New York you got all those
trucks okay you're going to be using
them for a while before their natural
life cycle ends and you're going to
replace them now it's the replacement
point where you have an opportunity and
you've seen that in New York City with
taxicabs I had a group at SEPA that
worked a few years ago on helping the
City Council of New York writing the new
rules that encourage the use of hybrid
taxicabs okay taxi cabs get replaced
very frequently
because these guys drive them in three
shifts on New York City streets and they
get beaten up pretty badly and so the
replacement cycle is pretty quick and so
that's a place where you can do
something in a hurry on that on the
other hand sanitation trucks and other
kinds of heavy material like that can
take a long time before they're ready
for replacement and so you have to be
able to encourage that now one of the
things government could do is you could
make the depreciation rules and other
tax incentives in place to allow that
turnover for more sustainable
technologies that's the way you could
accelerate some of these kinds of things
the other thing is newness sells people
don't want to use what they don't want a
you know a certified reused you know
Mercedes they want the new Mercedes
right all of you Mercedes owners out
there probably can talk about this but
people like something new okay something
that's tried-and-true and reused people
sometimes don't like and so part of the
financial issue here is Xerox has to
convince its people it's its consumers
rather that it's in their interest to
buy something that's been reconditioned
or at least some of the parts were used
before the other problem is is that's
also fundamental is that sustainability
savings tend to be long term but
business and politics and everything
else is organized around short term
revenues expenses and profits and so if
it's not going to get me a rapid return
then I'm not interested in it that's one
part of the financial issue the other is
capital costs now capital you have to
think about capital like it's a you know
like like it sort of rolls downhill
toward the highest rate of return as if
I can get an 8% return from your
business and a 6% from yours even if
yours is sustainable I'm going to go for
the 8% and then within the business if
the rate of return of invested capital
is higher for non sustainable
investments than for sustainable
investments
or perceived as higher doesn't even have
to be higher the capital won't go to the
to the renewable resource or to the
sustainability investment and
particularly in a time when capital
scarce and we're just coming out of that
period right now and the American
economy and the world economy then these
investments may not be attractive enough
to compete for scarce resources so that
it might act it might be profitable but
not profitable enough and that's the
kind of thing that you have to ask
yourself and they have to look at and
again government can play a role in this
so if you think about something like
municipal bonds municipal bonds have a
very healthy market because the federal
government and the state governments and
local governments don't tax the interest
on that and so when if I invest in those
kinds of bonds and I make you know ten
thousand dollars a profit I don't have
to pay any tax on that ten thousand
dollars that means that the government
can charge a lower rate when they go to
the bond market which makes it a more
attractive investment for everybody
that kind of tax expenditure by the
government can can move along socially
responsible investments and that's
something that needs to be used here the
other issue is uncertain return because
of new technologies some of the
technologies needed for sustainability
member the other side of what I just
said before that we don't know how to do
some of these things as we develop ways
of doing these things they're going to
be new and new technologies will have a
less certain rate of return it increases
the level of risk and can discourage
companies from allocating capital to
sustainability initiatives so these this
is the financial challenge of
sustainability management that you're
dealing with new technologies and
uncertain returns longer-term invests
longer-term payoffs rather than shorter
term payoffs all of which can lead to
problems here so now we've talked about
the technology we've talked about the
finance let's talk about organizations
in management again this came up during
your discussion of the case studies
earlier
sometimes you need a dramatic change in
management culture to bring about
sustainability initiatives I talked
about this before an organization with
an aggressive
damla torpedo you know approach to work
processes you know waste is just the
cost to do business needs to slow down
and think and adapt some of the things
that we heard about in the first hour
but they're too busy you know being out
there making decisions and and making
things happen and we can't really worry
about how much energy we're using
because energy is just a sort of sight
idea here we're interested in whatever
business were in organizations that
think of wasted water energy and
resource use as breakage or simply the
cost of doing business sometimes require
a complete cultural transformation the
people inside the organization have to
adopt different values and so new
standard operating procedures must be
developed and new technologies have to
be learned and adopted it's not just the
technology has to exist the people in
the organization have to know how to use
it they have to know how to take those
technologies and put them to work during
the work processes okay just like you
know HP may send you you know the the
box to put your toner in but if you
throw the toner in the garbage that
whole thing doesn't work you have to put
the toner in the box you have to seal
the box put the label on it and wait for
ups to come and get it and if you don't
like doing that or you don't know how to
do it or you're can't be bothered with
it it won't happen and those are
standard operating procedures every
organization as I said earlier is built
on those things so staff have to be
trained to understand how to perform the
new tasks and how to use the new
equipment and management is to learn
have supervise these new tests without
lost production momentum you can't end
up producing less while you're learning
how to do this stuff you've got to learn
how to do this stuff and keep producing
at the same level you were producing
before the changing technological base
of modern production and the impact of
rapid communication along with the globe
economy put organizations under enormous
pressure
in other words organizational life is
harder now people work longer hours they
got these things tethered to them
they're expected to respond you know you
know I'm gonna be watching the Yankees
later on hopefully beating Minnesota and
I'll be sitting there with this thing in
case one of my supervisors decides that
they need to ping me with something you
know it's I know a lot of people live
that way now and it's not fun so add to
that oh now you also want me to worry
about putting my toner in a box you know
go away I got enough to do you have a
24/7 global economy with people in the
financial world waking up in the middle
of the night because of markets and
other parts of the world you have
products that are that it requiring you
to ship things from everywhere and
manufacture them everywhere else and and
now we're gonna add to that this other
variable and for some people it's just
overload sustainability is not the only
challenge faced by modern organizations
but here's the point I would make about
just like the companies that needed to
adapt to the web and to containerized
shipping and to the global network of
production and services so too will
organizations need to adapt to this in
other words the point that I'll be
making throughout this semester and
you've heard me say it a few times is
that that excellent management is going
to be sustainability management you're
not going to be able to get away with
wasting water and product and energy and
and dumping pollution into the river in
the next 10 or 20 years if you're going
to be a successful manager and you see
in the best-run corporations that this
is part of how they're thinking about
themselves now this is not I mean it's a
revolution but it's not something that
is really that outlandish it's really
part of how the best drug companies are
thinking about themselves and so you're
gonna see more and more of this going on
so there's a management challenge but I
think it's going to be met you look at
companies like shale oil or like Pepsi
or like Walmart and
whole bunch of other organizations
they're thinking about this now it's
part of how their top management is
approaching organizational management so
then that brings me to government which
is the thing I actually probably know
the best in terms of my own expertise
how do we make this happen in the
private sector or the governmental
sector you know one of the interesting
things that I saw and the times
yesterday I don't know if I assume many
of you read this but as the military in
Afghanistan is starting to think about
using renewable energy in their combat
operations for a whole set of
interesting reasons one is its lower
cost two is that the oil tankers and the
trucks keep getting blown up and are
very vulnerable targets and three they
think that this kind of practice will
make them a more effective fighting
force because then they also don't have
to wait for unreliable resources to
arrive okay so now we see something very
interesting happening in sustainability
which is the government itself which is
a huge purchaser of all sorts of
Technology you know we'll be forcing
this technology into the marketplace
because when the military buys solar
cells or water purification units solar
water purification units they buy a lot
of them and they buy a lot of them in a
hurry now some of the one of the things
that came up in this article in the
paper yesterday was that some of these
technologies are unproven and they're a
little nervous about them but the
military people are saying the benefits
outweigh the cost even if we have some
failure here it's better than the way
we're operating and so government as a
consumer of goods and services can play
an enormous role government structures
incentives to the tax codes and
disincentives through regulation one of
the reasons why companies stop dumping
toxic waste into the ground next door or
into the river is that under the
Superfund bill they were now subject to
joint strict to the several liability
which means that if
I dumped something next door and even if
there were other people dumping all they
do is fine mine I'm not responsible for
the whole dump site I'm responsible for
cleaning it up and for any damages to
people who were exposed to this stuff
now that tells me that I better protect
myself by being a little bit better
environmental steward the other issue
was using the tax code because of the
financial issues I mentioned before if
we could use the tax code creatively we
could attract a lot more capital into
these this kind of R&D and into this
kind of product use and finally you need
the government itself to fund the
research and this is you know I'm
executive director of the earth is too
you know we get over 80% of our money
which is 120 million dollars a year from
the federal government so the federal
government should give us more you know
that's what I think and I think it was
more you know we can develop more
cutting-edge technologies so that's part
of what government has to do government
has to play a role in developing the
technology in developing the incentives
through the tax code and through
regulation and government has to through
its purchasing power become a consumer
okay
so a sustainability management then you
know I talked about the technical
challenges the financial challenge is
the organizational challenge the issues
for government and public policy so
again this is a pattern you should get
familiar with throughout the semester so
let me conclude here sustainability is a
key management concept as important or
more important than financial management
information management strategy
marketing and organizational management
know those are the first couple weeks of
the semester I talked to you about the
fundamentals of management and here's a
way to think about it though these
physical dimensions of sustainability
these constraints that that come from
resource use and waste are as
fundamental as any other management
constraint or opera
and organization faces and you need to
be thinking about management as
including these kinds of issues
it can't be ignored or assumed away no
economist Tory saying you know assume
this or assume that you know all things
held equal okay
well resources and waste can no longer
be held equal because there are almost 7
billion people on the planet our use of
resources is growing exponentially and
if we don't start managing ourselves and
managing the planet managing this
production function we are going to
start destroying the ability for it to
provide for us to the extent that we use
fossil fuels and one-time resources
whatever they are
whether it's iron ore whether it's coal
or whether it's oil these are substances
that were created geologically and
aren't coming back once we use them and
dump them into a landfill I actually
believe it's probably a hundred years
from now we're gonna mine landfills for
their resources because it's going to be
cheaper than trying to find the stuff
and the rest of the planet but think
about the opportunity we have now by
building into the production cycle as
much reuse as possible and also building
the production cycle on renewable you
know photosynthesis solar power are the
fundamental basis for resources that
will come back ok and so if we need to
think about that as the basis for our
economy I believe that all competent
business management will soon be
sustainability management and I'll say
this again all competent managers will
be sustainability managers because you
know can you manage an organization
without understanding a financial
statement without accounting can you
imagine organization without
understanding people and doing human
resource management or information or
strategy no so why do you think you can
manage an organization without
understanding the physical dimensions of
the organization's resource use its use
of resources and its and its production
of waste of course you have to know that
every manager is going to need to know
it whether you're the president
of a university the Dean of a school or
you're the head of a hotel or Kroger
you're going to need to understand these
kinds of things and you need to be
competent in it